bienvenidos de nuevo a mi presentación
es acerca de los títulos respaldados por
hipotecas así que demos un repaso de
todo lo que hemos visto hice un pequeño
resumen sobre todo lo que teníamos para
irnos un poco más deprisa así que aquí
he dibujado de todo lo que hemos venido
hablando así que vamos a ir un poco de
memoria nosotros empezamos con una
cierta cantidad de personas que pedían
dinero aquí tenemos a todos estos
prestatarios que querían comprar su casa
y cada uno de ellos pedía un millón de
pesos y si también hacen un poco de
memoria nosotros teníamos a mil personas
que tenían el mismo caso mil personas
que pedían un millón de pesos entonces
aquí tengo a los prestatarios
multiplicados por mil y después dijimos
que un millón multiplicado por mil era
lo mismo que mil millones que es lo que
necesitaba el banco y también nosotros
habíamos comentado que ellos iban a
pagar una tasa de interés fija del 10
por ciento de la cantidad que le habían
prestado es decir cada uno pagaba 100
mil pesos durante cada año y como
tenemos a mil prestatarios entonces
esta tarde os x 100.000 me da 100
millones de pesos y bueno también
recordemos que todo este dinero se iba a
la entidad de propósito especial era
esta compañía que estaba designada para
crear la estructura de los títulos
respaldados por hipotecas y bueno
después nos preguntamos de dónde sacaba
dinero esta entidad de propósito
especial y nosotros nos dimos cuenta que
esta compañía sacaba dinero de los
inversionistas que compraban los títulos
respaldados por hipotecas y bueno hay
que ser muy claros el activo de esta
entidad de propósito especial son los
préstamos entonces voy a escribirlo los
préstamos son el activo principal y de
estos activos además va a recibir lo que
obtiene del interés que le pagan de este
10 por ciento y bueno el dinero viene
entonces también de estos propietarios
de los títulos de respaldo por hipotecas
y también habíamos dicho que cada título
de respaldo por hipotecas valía mil
pesos y bueno ellos obtenían a cambio
esta tasa de interés del 10 por ciento
por lo tanto ellos
mil pesos para comprar subtítulo de
respaldo por hipotecas y ellos obtienen
a cambio 100 pesos por mes 100 pesos es
el 10% pero si te das cuenta en el vídeo
pasado dijimos que esta empresa emitía
un millón de acciones o dicho de otra
manera emite un millón de títulos de
respaldo por hipotecas y un millón por
mil me da mil millones y es justo de
aquí de donde vienen o de dónde aparecen
estos mil millones que esencialmente es
el dinero que van a obtener los
prestatarios y bueno también toma en
cuenta que lo que habíamos dicho es que
ninguno de esos prestatarios falla en
sus pagos
ninguno de ellos deja de pagar ninguno
de ellos es incumplido y ninguno de
ellos hace un prepago un prepago de una
hipoteca sería vender la casa y entonces
pues paga el dinero de vuelta y ya no
necesita este préstamo así que en un
mundo un poco más real pues podríamos
decir que tal vez no obtengan esta tasa
de interés del 10% tal vez te obtengan
un porcentaje menor es decir supongamos
que alguno de estos deudores no puede
pagar a tiempo o se atrasen sus pagos o
ya no puede pagar
desgracia que pueda pasar y bueno esto
también lo tiene que tener en cuenta
aquel que es el propietario de este
título de respaldo por hipotecas y tal
vez en algún momento hayas leído algún
artículo sobre como las computadoras
calculan precisamente el porcentaje que
vas a obtener de vuelta cuando tú compra
subtítulos de respaldo por hipotecas y
es justo es lo que calculan los modelos
computacionales ellos buscan en toda la
historia de datos y entre esos datos lo
que van a tener es en qué parte del país
se está dando esta deuda para qué tipo
de población se está dando esta deuda y
cuál es el porcentaje de esta población
que tiene posibilidades de pagar esta
hipoteca y bueno por lo tanto también
cuál es la probabilidad y el porcentaje
de que las personas no cumplan su deuda
aclaró y también cuál va a ser el precio
de no pagar por ejemplo si nosotros
pensamos en la entidad de propósito
especial si ellos no cumplen con su pago
de este millón de pesos entonces lo que
van a obtener a cambio es la casa hay un
cierto riesgo en cada préstamo que está
haciendo bueno supongamos que toda esta
cantidad de prestatarios falla en un 20%
aquí está entonces 20 por ciento de
ellos
en sus pagos es decir pueden hacer un
prepago o de planes no van antes del
dinero para pagar y bueno si calculamos
el 20 por ciento de estos mil
prestatarios vamos a decir que 200 son
los que sufren la desgracia de perder su
trabajo o lo que sea por lo tanto ellos
no van a poder seguir pagando esta
hipoteca y entonces vamos a tener que
cobrar nos con su casa y bueno si nos
compramos con su casa entonces solamente
obtenemos el 50% de regreso porque al
final por cada casa que nosotros
marquemos porque no pueden seguir
pagando la deuda vamos a obtener
solamente la mitad es decir 500 mil
pesos por lo tanto de vuelta obtenemos
solamente 50% de lo que prestamos y
bueno si tenemos 20% que no pagan y
obtenemos solamente el 50% de vuelta
entonces estamos diciendo que el 10% de
esta deuda vale menos y bueno todo eso
porque nosotros tenemos un número grande
de deudores mil deudores pero si
nosotros hablamos solamente de un deudor
pues nuestro anda muy lógico hablar de
un 20 por ciento de que no pague el
deudor o paga o no paga esto es
solamente una suposición y bueno
contando de que si tenemos a esto
deudores si entonces estamos hablando
que el 10% de la deuda vale menos
entonces esto quiere decir que de esta
tasa fija del 10% que nosotros vamos a
obtener vamos a obtener el 10% menos
porque vale menos nuestra deuda y el 10%
de 10% pues es 1% entonces realmente lo
que vamos a obtener es un 9% de tasa de
interés y bueno esto estamos hablando de
un modelo un poco más realista y de este
modelo que estamos construyendo ojo es
el modelo que nosotros construimos y es
muy importante que les diga esto porque
puede cambiar estos porcentajes tal vez
en algún otro modelo estamos hablando de
otro país y de otras circunstancias y
entonces el porcentaje de personas que
no paguen de suba al 50% y esto va a
afectar a que obtengas menos de la
ganancia original y bueno para qué
estamos haciendo todo este análisis
porque si nosotros pensamos en un banco
cotidiano lo que estamos pensando es que
este banco tiene su propio modelo pero
en este caso estamos hablando de un
banco de inversión de hecho los bancos
cotidianos tienen una clase de personas
a los cuales no les prestan dinero
mientras que hay otros que tienen
crediticio perfecto ellos tienen un buen
salario y entonces no tienen ningún
problema para obtener un préstamo y
también toma ojo si tú no cumples los
requisitos que te pide el banco pues
simple y sencillamente el banco no te
presta el dinero sin embargo aquí
estamos hablando de inversionistas y
pueda ver que hay inversionistas que
digan bueno existe un riesgo mayor y sin
embargo yo quiero invertir 10 justo por
lo cual hay un mayor riesgo en estos
títulos de respaldo por hipotecas así
que mejor vamos a suponer que todos
estos deudores todas estas personas que
van a pedir el dinero para comprar sus
casas ellos son personas que no van a
necesitar todos estos tipos de
requisitos pero entonces no están
cumpliendo los requisitos básicos pero
también vamos a pensar el lado positivo
supongamos que ellos tienen un buen
salario o tal vez tengan un buen
historial crediticio entonces podría ir
a este mecanismo alternativo de hablar
de los títulos de respaldo por hipotecas
es decir lo que voy a buscar es
inversionistas que les quieran prestar
que les quieran prestar el dinero para
pagar sus casas es decir en este punto
de vista lo que estoy tomando en cuenta
es que tienen mayor facilidad para
un acceso al préstamo que quieren y
visto desde el punto del inversionista
un inversionista tiene un lugar donde
pueda invertir tal vez sienta que los
modelos computacionales tengan una
predicción bastante buena de lo que va a
pasar acerca de esta tasa de inversión
puede ser que yo se obtenga de vuelta
todo el dinero que preste y que nos
digan que este préstamo no es malo y tal
vez estemos pensando que nosotros vamos
ser unos mejores prestadores que los
prestadores que tiene un banco
entonces en resumidas cuentas m es un
lugar atractivo para invertir además me
gusta el riesgo porque este tipo de
inversión pues va a tener un cierto
riesgo que el mercado tradicional no
existe y sin embargo yo voy a obtener un
cierto capital de todo esto que voy a
invertir y bueno todo esto fue para
darles un resumen de qué es lo que
estaba pasando sobre los títulos de
respaldo por hipotecas en el siguiente
vídeo creo lo que yo quiero darles es
talvez complicarles un poquito menos la
existencia lo que quiero es que abramos
esta inversión a un grupo mayor de
inversionistas y tengamos una cierta
cantidad de inversionistas que digan a
mí me parece bien a mí me parece
correcto
que me den una tasa del 9% anual a mí me
gusta la adrenalina yo soy un excelente
jugador y le entro y bueno por lo tanto
al darse este lujo entonces ellos van a
obtener a cambio una mayor cantidad de
tasa de interés aunque también cabe
decir que hay algunos inversionistas los
cuales no les gusta el riesgo y por lo
tanto no van a entrar al negocio todo
esto es justo lo que te quiero enseñar
en la siguiente presentación en el vídeo
de obligación de deudas garantizadas nos
vemos pronto